you know when you restrict somebody like
Hector from running his business and
when you hit him with fines and
prohibitions and you give him all these
kinds of restrictions you're not you're
not killing some big business what
you're doing is actually harming you
know in this case immigrant guys hi I'm
Nicolas be with reason TV and today
we're talking with Sean Malone he's the
creative media director at the Charles
Koch Institute and he's heading up
something called honest Enterprise TV
Sean thanks for talking to us tasty
honest Enterprise dot TV you have a
video up there about an entrepreneur
named Hector Ricketts what's the story
and why should we be watching it yeah
Hector is a to Macon immigrant who moved
here about actually moved to Queens New
York in about nineteen seventy eight and
he moved here actually to do to get an
education and then quickly learned that
he'd like to be an entrepreneur what he
does is takes people to work in commuter
vans he built this whole industry of
these vans that go up and down basically
any of the streets where you typically
don't get a lot of buses in Brooklyn
Queens the Bronx or tax season taxi it's
really really hard to find and so they
they really filled the gap where the
city was really lacking in that case and
he brings he fairies a lot of people who
do healthcare work and other types of
kind of helping profession they take
healthcare workers personal care workers
out to Staten Island where they have
serious problems getting getting the
care that they need because Staten
Island just doesn't have enough of those
types of workers what's the what's the
conflict in the circuits I mean the
video which is online and is about 20
minutes long is really interesting
documentary talks about him building up
that business but there's more to the
story than that at first they were sort
of a to operate by the state really kind
of grey market territory where they they
didn't weren't really authorized but
they could do charters and things like
that and then in i want to say 1994 the
city council took over the authorization
process and they created moratorium they
completely shut down
the authorizations for vans and it was
really at the behest of the the transit
workers union at the time which saw them
as competition to the city buses we went
to Albany we went to City Hall and we
love it we demonstrated we block the
streets just to get attention we reached
out to the press we're here to push for
legislation that would provide an
industry that came into being a result
as a result of poor and efficient
service by the Transit Authority ten
years ago we will continue to lobby to
fight to negotiate with the city and the
state until our business is free of the
stranglehold that local laws have on us
eventually the Institute for justice who
you guys probably know pretty well took
on a case litigated that case in I think
1997 and actually removed the City
Council from that process but the Vans
actually still have tons and tons of
legal restrictions and authorization
restrictions they have to do all kinds
of things that are way beyond what any
of the taxis are the buses have to do is
so I mean this is a compelling story of
an immigrant who creates a business
that's really doing you no good stuff
gets screwed over by the government wins
with the help of a libertarian law firm
what are the you also have other videos
at the site at on its enterprise not TV
and what did what are those go into and
what's what's the idea behind the whole
package of videos what we're planning on
doing with the site is actually more
stories like this we'd like to tell
entrepreneurship stories we want to show
the value of entrepreneurs want to show
the hardship that a lot of them face
that I think a lot of people don't
really know that much about you take for
granted guys like Hector because you
just get on the van and you drive to
your work or whatever and the knee hop
often it's two dollars to ride so it's
hardly a thought in your day but the
reality is these guys actually make a
really big difference they serve about
50,000 maybe 60,000 people in Queens and
Brooklyn which we actually discovered
recently is actually exceeds most city
bus it busts
and public transit systems entirely so
it's a huge number of people do you have
a sense of what the next project is
going to be bad or the next story that
you'll be telling ya right now the next
one that's on deck for me is as a hair
braiding case that's in Mississippi and
I'm sure probably a lot of people have
heard a few things about cosmetology
licensing and hair braiders right which
is kind of nuts right in almost every
state you've got to go through hours and
hours of schooling and indentured
servitude or whatever right before you
can cut hair or do anything yeah in this
case it's one of the most ridiculous
examples you can think of it's I think
it was two thousand hours of training
plus an additional 500 hours of
something else it was a ton of training
a ton of time and not a single bit of it
actually covered hair braiding they did
they did a case on that as well and when
they won new shops opened up from people
coming in from out of state anglea so
Mississippi's actually created jobs and
like they've brought new people in I've
reducing regulation by using some very
talk a little bit about how honest
Enterprise fits into the larger mission
of the Charles Koch Institute yeah i
mean the mission overall is to promote
freedom in society i mean really to
advance liberty and a big part of that's
always been championing economic freedom
and so this is really right in line with
that I mean the goal is to show not in a
heavy-handed way but to show that these
are real concerns for real people and
that you know when you restrict somebody
like Hector from running his business
and when you hit him with fines and
prohibitions and you give them all these
kinds of restrictions you're not you're
not killing some big business what
you're doing is actually harming you
know in this case immigrant guys like
these are guys who came over here for no
other really no other reason one of the
guys in the documentary says you know if
we wanted beaches we'd stay in Jamaica
well we'll leave it there i want to
thank Shaun Maloney's the creative media
director at the Charles Koch Institute
and he's running a new website called
honest Enterprise TV check it out and
especially the document
that's up there about Hector Ricketts
who runs a van commuting service Sean
thanks so much for talking thanks very
much alright for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie